HEY, GUYS.
[claps]
EXCUSE ME.
MY HUSBAND, THE PRESIDENT--
HE'S VERY TIRED,
AND HE WILL BE RESTING.
SO HE NEEDS TO REST.
BUT AT THIS POINT,
THE CONGRESS WAS LIKE,
THE PRESIDENT HASN'T
COME OUTSIDE IN A COUPLE WEEKS.
WHAT'S HE DOING?
AND SO THEY KNOCK ON THE DOOR,
LIKE, 'SCUSE ME!
IT'S ME, CONGRESS.
WE'RE HAVING A FEELING THAT--
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT WE'RE FEELING,
BUT CAN YOU TALK TO US?
AND SHE'S LIKE,
NO, HE'S JUST SUPER TIRED.
HE HAS EXHAUSTION.
LIKE, DON'T BOTHER HIM.
GET OUT OF HERE, CONGRESS.
AND THAT
ACTUALLY QUIETED PEOPLE.
IT ACTUALLY QUIETED
THE CONGRESS.
AND SHE EVEN WENT TO CONGRESS
AND WAS LIKE,
HEY, NO BIG DEAL.
I'M GIVING HIM EVERYTHING
YOU'RE SAYING, CONGRESS.
I'M GIVING HIM ALL
THE LETTERS AND OTHER THINGS.
SO, WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK
OF THIS RULE
OR A LAW OR THING
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON?
AND THEY'D BE LIKE,
WHATEVER, WE THINK THIS.
AND THEN SHE'D BRING IT
TO WOODROW WHO WAS LIKE,
HALF AWAKE,
AND SHE'D BE LIKE, ALL RIGHT.
WELL, CONGRESS IS LIKE,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
AND HE'D BE LIKE...
[mumbles indistinctly]
AND SHE WAS LIKE,
WELL, I GUESS I'LL COMPROMISE.
I'M JUST GONNA [bleep]
MAKE THE DECI--
[stammers]
MAKE THE DECISIONS MYSELF.
SO BASICALLY, EDITH WILSON WAS
THE FIRST FEMALE PRESIDENT.
SHE RAN MEMOS BETWEEN
CONGRESS AND HIM.
CONGRESS IS LIKE, ALL RIGHT.
WHAT? WHAT?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
SO CONGRESS PICKED THIS ONE
REPUBLICAN SENATOR, ALBERT FALL.
THEY'RE LIKE, ALBERT, GO SEE
WHAT HIS TRUE CONDITION IS.
GO SEE WHAT WILSON'S
TRUE CONDITION IS.
SO ALBERT FALL SHOWS UP.
HE'S LIKE, CAN WE COME IN
AND SEE THE TRUE CONDITION?
SHE'S NOT [bleep] STUPID.
SHE'S LIKE YEAH, SURE.
COME ON IN.
SO ALBERT FALL COMES IN.
[dramatic music]
♪
IT WAS LIKE, YEP,
HE'S NOT--THIS IS HIM.
MAKING DECISIONS EVERY DAY,
AND NOT I--TAKE THE--
THANK YOU, HONEY.
AND I TAKE THE--
THE PAPERS FROM HIM
THAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND
'CAUSE I'M JUST SOME DUMB BROAD.
AND EDITH JUST PROPPED UP
WOODROW IN BED.
LIKE, WAVING, LIKE HEY.
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
OH, OKAY. COOL.
AND SHE'S LIKE, BYE.
AND THEN THEY LEAVE.
THAT'S HOW DUMB GOVERNMENT IS.
WE HAD A WOMAN [bleep] RUNNING
THIS COUNTRY,
AND GUESS WHAT?
YOU COULD GO,
NOTHING GOOD HAPPENED,
BUT I CAN GO,
NOTHING BAD HAPPENED.
9/11 DIDN'T HAPPEN
ON HER WATCH.
DISNEYLAND WITH JOHNNY DEPP
AT THE ANI--
THE--HO--THE HAUNTED MANSION
THAT'S ALL TIM BURTON--
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
ON HER WATCH.
CHRISTMAS
AND HALLOWEEN COMBINED,
A LOT OF THINGS--
- [chuckles]